Transcriber: Bilge Yilmaz
Gözden geçirme: Gözde Caymazer
Prof. Dr. Haluk Gürgen
BAU Öğretim Görevlisi
Evet günaydın arkadaşlar.
Hoş geldiniz.
Çok küçüktüm ortaokul falan sıralarında.
Benim okuduğum okulda da böyle
ayda bir veli toplantısı yapılırdı.
Bu toplantılar gece olurdu.
Yaklaşık bu kadar büyük değilse de
buna yakın bir salonda,
yapılan bu toplantıların ayda bir
tekrarı söz konusuydu.
Ben de o toplantılarda
genellikle şiir okurdum.
Çok da güzel okuduğumu söylerdi hocamız.
Allah rahmet eylesin Zehra Hanım.
Ve ben kendime çok güveniyorum,
yani ezberim de çok iyi.
Bu anlatacağım olayın
meydana geldiği gece,
hiç yanıma şiirin metnini
falan almadan çıktım.
Sizin gibi böyle kalabalığı
görünce dondum kaldım.
Niye böyle oldu anlayamadım.
Çünkü çok iyi okuyan,
kendine güvenen bir adamdım.
Ve tek bir sözcük aklıma gelmiyordu.
Böyle kulis falan da yok.
Yani sufle verilecek bir durum da yok.
Öğretmenim Zehra Hanım böyle
emekleyerek neredeyse geldi
ve bana şiirin ilk dizesini söyledi.
Ben ondan sonra sular seller
gibi şiiri tamamladım.
Ama, o ilk dizenin söylenmesinden önce
ben sürekli böyle selam veriyorum.
Veliler, öğrenciler şaşkın bir vaziyette.
Sonra ikinci selamı veriyorum,
üçüncüsünde kahkaha atmaya başladılar.
Ben selam vermeye devam ediyorum.
Selam verirsem sanki şiiri
hatırlayacakmışım gibi düşünüyorum.
İşte o Zehra hocam Allah rahmet eylesin
geldi ve dedi ki bu dizenin hani başla.
Ben ondan sonra bitirdim.
Fakat nasıl mahçubum, nasıl
utandım, inanamazsınız.
Netice itibariyle ertesi günü
okul var tabii, gittim.
Yüzümü kaldıramıyorum,
Türkçe dersinde ilk saat.
Hiç unutmuyorum sanki hiçbir şey olmamış
gibi hocam geldi öğretmenim,
önümüzdeki ay elinde tuttuğu şiiri bana
verdi bunu çalış, bunu okuyacaksın dedi.
Bu çok önemli bir şey bence.
Çünkü o hocam bana bunu yapmamış olsaydı,
ben bugün sizin huzurunuzda olamazdım.
Dahası çok uzun yıllardır hocalık
yapıyorum, hocalık mesleğini yapamazdım.
Bana dokundu, beni orada küçültmedi,
beni azarlamadı, beni var etti orada.
Ve ben ondan sonra hep bu tarz
konuşmalar yaparken
şöyle bir kağıdı yanıma alarak
çıkmaya başladım.
Bunu öğrendim ve bunun pratikte de
çok işe yaradığını gördüm.
O nedenle bu TED'in formatına
pek uygun değil ama
ben neme lazım yanımda
bulunsun istiyorum.
Evet.
Şimdi bu momentum,
Bana dediler ki Momentum ana tema,
onun üzerine konuşacaksın.
Benim de fizikten filan böyle
pek anladığım bir şey değil.
Gerçekten anlamıyorum.
Araştırdım.
Sonra bizim beraber çalıştığımız
arkadaşlarımızdan bir tanesi,
böyle bayağı bu konulara
yakın birisidir, ona sordum.
Hiç merak etme hocam dedi,
hallederiz dedi.
Bana bir takım şeyler anlattı.
Benim de kafama yattı.
Bildiğim anlamın dışında da hani böyle
bir metafor olarak kullanıldığında,
çok da farklı bir şey
olmadığını fark ettim.
Evet momentum cisimlerin ve kütlelerin
hareketiyle ilgili bir fizik dalı.
Ben de iletişimciyim hasbelkader.
Ben de insanların ve toplumların
etkileşimi üzerine,
anlamı paylaşmakla ilgili konular
üzerine çalışıyorum.
Fakat daha da önemlisi,
ya bu giderek,
bu iletişim ne korkunç bir şey oldu ya.
Farkında mısınız?
Yani iktidar olmak istiyorsanız
iletişimi çok iyi bilmek
ve kullanmak durumundasınız.
Dolayısıyla mal satmak istiyorsanız
iletişim kullanmak zorundasınız.
Teknolojisi bir taraftan,
işin psikolojisi başka bir taraftan.
Bütün bunlarla uğraşan bir
bilim alanı hâline geldi iletişim.
Disiplinler arası bir alan.
Yani içinde insan bilimlerinin
bütün dalları var.
Yetmiyor teknolojisi var.
Bir iletişimle uğraşıyorum
dediğiniz vakit de
bütün bunlardan bir şeyleri dikkate almak,
öğrenmek, bilmek durumundasınız.
O nedenle benim burada anlatacaklarım,
aslında bu çok geniş alanın
yüzeyindeki konulara ilişkin birtakım
böyle dokunuşlar olacak.
Her birinin arka planında
çok önemli teoriler var.
Bunların adını vererek
sıkıcı olmak istemiyorum.
Ama hani burada da konuşurken
''adam da böyle yüzeysel konuştu geçti''
diye düşünmeyin.
Emin olun dürüst ve samimi olarak
bunların arka planına ilişkin de
çok şeyi okudum, onların üzerinden
sizlere bahsedeceğim.
Ama iletişim dediğimiz şey arkadaşlar,
''anlam paylaşımı''.
Bir kere bu anlamın
paylaşılabilmesi için,
ortak bir dil üzerinden
konuşmamız gerekiyor
ve birbirimizi dinlememiz gerekiyor,
anlamamız gerekiyor.
Gayet güzel.
Fakat bizim maalesef bir üzerinde
durmamız gereken sıkıntımız var.
Eğer bu paylaşımın
gerçekleşmesini istiyorsanız
karşınızdaki kişiyi
ötekileştirmeyeceksiniz.
Bu ötekileştirme çok ciddi bir problem.
Yani cinsiyetten ötürü ötekileştirme,
ırktan ötürü ötekileştirme,
mezhebinden ötürü ötekileştirme,
hiyerarşideki pozisyonundan
ötürü ötekileştirme,
fiziki olarak gözünüze hoş
görünmediği için ötekileştirme,
cahil gördüğünüz için ötekileştirme,
yaşı sizden küçük ya da büyük
olduğu için ötekileştirme.
Bu konuyu aşmadığımız taktirde
iletişim kuramayız.
Bugün dünyanın en temel
problemlerinin başında bu geliyor.
Teorik olarak baktığınız vakit de
gerçekten çok şey yazılıp
çizilen bir konu.
Şimdi Türkiye’ye baktığımız vakit
bu ötekileştirme ile ilgili
benim çalıştığım üniversitede sevgili
hocam Yılmaz Esmer’in yaptığı
değerler araştırması var.
İki yılda bir Avrupa Ölçeği'ni
Türkiye’de o yönetiyor.
%70 oranında seyrediyor
değerli arkadaşlar.
LGBT bireyleriyle aynı apartmanda
oturmak istemiyorum diyenler.
İnanılmaz bir homofobi.
Kürdüyle, Ermenisiyle, Rumuyla
aynı yerde oturmak istemiyorum
diyenlerin de oranı yaklaşık bu kadar.
Şimdi böyle bir durumda hangi
paylaşmaktan söz ediyorsunuz.
Bence bu noktanın üzerinde
durmakta yarar var.
Hepimiz birbirimizden farklıyız,
farklı da olmamız gerekir.
Biricik olmamız gerekir.
Çünkü bizler her birimiz biriciğiz.
Güzel.
Fakat bu farklılıkları böyle
derinleştirmek değil,
farklılıklar arasındaki benzerlikleri
çoğaltmamız lazım.
Sorun burada.
Bunun için de ötekileştirmekten değil
birlikte bir şeyleri anlamaktan,
birbirimizi anlamaktan yola çıkarak
bu benzerliği arttırmak
durumunda olmalıyız diye düşünüyorum.
Şimdi kafamızda birtakım şemalar var.
İyilere ilişkin, doğrulara ilişkin,
düzenlere ilişkin,
her konuda, her durumla
ilgili şemalar var.
Algıladığınız her bir uyaranı o
şemalarla ilişkilendiriyoruz,
eğer kafamıza uyuyorsa doğrudur diyoruz.
Tamam, sen bendensin diyoruz.
Değilse reddediyoruz,
yanlıştır diyoruz.
Ya da durup düşünüyoruz.
Ya doğruysa?
Bir anlamaya çalışayım dediğiniz an,
işte iletişim başlıyor demektir.
Arkadaşlar, iletişimde iki kişinin
konuşmasında
ortak bir noktaya varmak gerekmiyor.
Birisinin dediğini diğerinin
evet demesi gerekmiyor.
Evet ben seni dinledim, ne demek
istediğini de anladım,
ama katılmıyorum.
Fakat günlük hayatımızda
bu böyle mi çalışıyor?
Sizin dediğinizi karşı taraf
anladım katılmıyorum dediğiniz vakit
siz bozuluyorsunuz.
Yani her şeyde bir uzlaşım içerisinde
olmak zorunluluğumuz yok.
Bir dur bakalım bir düşün.
Belki de gerçekten anladın
kabul etmedin,
neden kendi değerlerine döndün,
neden kabul etmediğini bir sorgula.
Ya da kabul ettin,
neden kabul ettiğini sorgula.
İşte bu şekilde bir sorgulama süreci
içerisinde didiklediğimiz vakit,
çok da fazla böyle didiklemekten
hani yana da olmamak lazım.
Ama başka bir dünya açılıyor
gözümüzün önüne.
Bu dünyanın adı
‘’İdeoloji Dünyası’’ arkadaşlar.
İdeoloji günlük hayatımızdaki
her nesneyi, her konuyu, her olayı,
algılayış ve değerlendirişimizin
ana meselesi.
Benim görsellerim vardı.
Vallahi bravo. Evet.
Teşekkür ederim arkadaşlar.
Dolayısıyla bu meseleyle
ilgili baktığımız vakit
bu momentum daha ziyade,
böyle bir denizde hareket hâlindeki cisim
üzerinden anlatılıyor biliyorsunuz.
Bizde bir gemiye binmişiz arkadaşlar.
Bu geminin çarkları da
bir şekilde çalışıyor.
İşte o çarkları belirli bir yöne hareket
ettiren itkiye biz ideoloji diyoruz.
Dolayısıyla bu ideolojinin
farkına vardığımız vakit,
işin farklı bir boyutu gözümüzün
önüne seriliveriyor.
Şimdi ideoloji falan deyince politik
bir konuşma gibi falan gibi düşünmeyin.
Yani nefes aldığımız bu dünyanın
aslında harcı ideoloji.
Bizi birbirimize bağlayan,
bizim birbirimizle ilişkilerimizin
anlamını üretmemizde son derece önemli
rol oynayan çok temel bir kavram.
Şimdi diyorum ki ben, bu dünyanın
bize öğrettiği doğruları
birileri yapındırmış.
Nasıl?
İşte televizyondaki dizilerden,
özellikle haberlerden,
çok fazla konuşan siyasilerimizin
meselelere ilişkin açıklamalarından,
günlük hayattaki pratiklerden beslenerek
birtakım kafamızda oluşan o doğruların,
eğer yapındırıldığını söylüyorsak, bunun
çözümlenebileceğini de söyleyebiliriz.
Bunu çözebilmek farklı bir dünyanın
kapılarını açmak anlamına geliyor.
Dolayısıyla,
bu konuda en önemli tetikleyici
bu dünyanın kapılarını açmada
en önemli tetikleyici,
bana göre değil sadece
birçok insana göre böyle.
Sanat, sevgili arkadaşlar.
Eğer sanat ile ilişkiyi sağlıklı
bir şekilde kurabilirsek,
yani bir sanatın pasif tüketicisi
olmak da problem değil.
Yani bir sergiye gitmek,
bir tiyatroya gitmek,
bir müzik dinlemek vesaire.
Buradaki pasif lafını geri alıyorum,
pasif değil.
Yani katılmak, onu tüketmek
anlamında kullanıyorum.
Ama özellikle işin bir
ucundan tutabiliyorsak,
yani bir koroya girip orada
şarkı söyleyebiliyorsak,
ne bileyim panellere katılabiliyorsak,
amatör tiyatro yapabiliyorsak,
işte o zaman başka bir boyuta
geçmiş oluyoruz.
O sanat bize çok başka bir dünyanın
kapılarını aralamamıza neden oluyor.
Sis perdesini gözümüzün
önünden kaldırıyor.
Bakın Guernica diye bir tablo var
biliyorsunuz Picasso’nun.
İlk başta pek fazla bir şey
anlamıyorsunuz baktığınızda.
Şekiller desenler vesaire.
Fakat enteresan, inatla bakmaya,
anlamaya, sormaya,
sorgulamaya başladığınız vakit
bu tabloda bayağı ciddi bir şiddeti,
ezileni ve ezilenin başkaldırışını,
faşizime karşı direnişini
anlamaya, görmeye başladığınız vakit,
işte o sis perdesi de kalkmış oluyor.
Benim yine çok sevdiğim bir şiir var,
size onu okuyacağım.
Başkan güzel bir Nazım Hikmet
şiiri okudu çok severim.
Ben de bir okuyayım bakalım.
Melih Cevdet Anday’ın Ağaç şiiri.
Tanıdığım bir ağaç var
Etlik bağlarına yakın
Saadetin adını bile duymamış
Tanrının işine bakın.
Geceyi gündüzü biliyor
Dört mevsim, rüzgârı, karı
Ay ışığına bayılıyor
Ama kötülemiyor karanlığı.
Ona bir kitap vereceğim
Rahatını kaçırmak için
Bir öğrenegörsün aşkı
Ağacı o vakit seyredin.
Dolayısıyla işte sanat da
böyle bir etkiye sahip.
Bir kitap gibi.
Okuduğunuz vakit sayfaların arasından
başka bir ışık sizi karşılıyor.
O bakımdan bence o bastırılmış.
Çünkü hayatınız bu yüksek hızda
ve şiddetli bir şekilde gelişen
bu momentumun karşısında,
giderek böyle kendimizi geriye çekme,
yalnızlaşma ve de öğrenilmiş çaresizlik
diye adlandırdığımız duruma
bir kabullenme hâli içerisinde yaşamanın
sonucunda, bir depresyon içinde geçiyor.
Dolayısıyla buna baş
kaldırmak durumundayız.
Umudu asla ve asla
kaybetmemek durumundayız.
Umut birbirimizi, birbirimizle
beraber olmaktan geçiyor.
Dolayısıyla sokağa çıkmak gerekiyor.
Dolayısıyla başkalarıyla beraber
olmak gerekiyor.
Yani sivil toplum
kuruluşlarının içerisinde,
siyasi partilerin içerisinde,
sanat oluşumları içerisinde,
okuma grupları içerisinde,
ama birileri olacak.
O birileri ile birlikte birbirimizi
anlayarak çoğalmamız gerekiyor.
Burada hem birbirimizi anlayacağız,
hem de biricik olacağız.
Biricik olduğumuz vakit
bunun sorumluluğunu taşıyarak
kendimizi var edeceğiz.
Burası önemli.
Var etmek demek, hayatımıza
ilişkin birtakım soruların
yanıtını bulmak için çaba
harcamak demektir.
Ben nereye gidiyorum?
Nasıl gidiyorum?
Hangi değerleri koruyarak, kollayarak,
kendimi geliştirerek, nereye varacağım?
Ve de bütün bunlar için ne yapacağım?
İşte bu ''ne yapacağım'' sorusunun altında
cesaret, merak
ve de inadına yaşama arzusu
olması gerekiyor.
İletişim sizin nasıl
var olduğunuzla ilgili
bir tarz olarak karşımıza çıkıyor.
Siz ne iseniz iletişiminiz de o.
İletişimiz ne ise, siz de O'sunuz.
O nedenle şu ya da bu şekilde,
bindiğimiz bu gemilerin içerisinde,
o dümenin başında biz var mıyız yok muyuz,
var olabilmek için ne yapmamız gerekiyor,
kiminle neyi görüşmemiz,
neyi konuşmamız,
kimi neden anlamamız gerektiği
ve bu dünyada var olabilmenin
yolu nereden geçiyorsa
onun ışığıyla, onun yatırımıyla
kendimizi geleceğe taşımamız,
fevkalade önemli oluyor.
Dolayısıyla iletişim,
evet anlam paylaşımı.
Ama bu anlamları paylaşırken de
kendimize bakmamız
ve kendimizden yola çıkarak
başkalarına bakmamız
ve başkalarını anlayarak kendimizi
üretmemiz, büyütmemiz
ve bu var olma süreci içerisinde
bir şekilde yürümemiz gerekiyor.
Evet benim söyleyeceklerim bu kadar.
Ümit ederim birtakım mesajları,
birtakım düşüncelerimi
sizlerle paylaşma imkânı bulmuşumdur.
Çok teşekkür ediyorum.
Sağ olun.
(Alkış)